[Music]
hi guys my name is Tony Sebastian
I'm from Kerala India and I work in DBS
in Singapore and responsible for
delivering digital consumer products in
web and mobile across regions so here is
what I am I'll be covering today where I
will go through the journey that myself
and my team went through so I'll be
talking a little bit about the
challenges and how we set our mission
and the solution and the results that we
have observe and we want to highlight
that hopefully it will be a great
takeaway for you guys so the challenges
so in DBS scale we constantly have a
massive amount of innovative initiative
and enhancement in our pipeline and the
second one is we want to reduce
duplication of work so it's how very
hard to team to know that when somebody
have done something and how they can
reuse those components or anything to
their products so - we want to reduce
the duplication of work so even though
everything starts cymbal initially in a
product and over the time it grows and
we wipe you find very hard to handle the
UI complexity so UI will become very
complex so how do we handle that so
these are the couple of challenges that
we face in DBS particularly for the
product development
so given that challenges so my team have
collaborated with various stakeholders
like business design and legal
compliance to address how we can address
these challenges and we set up our
mission what what should be our mission
and one mission is that we have to build
a modern front-end development framework
which could accommodate our requirements
and number two we need to build
application and component bootstrap
which could actually eliminate repeating
work that the developers need to do so
that they can focus on writing the
business requirements so and number
three is build reusable components this
is to avoid developers to rebuild your
components which they have built before
and this would also help the
organization's to streamline the
branding across all products
so with all this layout I would like to
share what we have built and this might
be interesting to you and we released or
we developed a internal product we call
we call it Falcon
it's actually a UI framework with an
opinionated set of tools and
technologies and best practices to
enable heavy reuse of the code across
different team countries within DBS or
within our company
and we have built three important
pillars a one is app structure
generators and your component library
and we choose react and redux as the
base with other libraries and with all
the capabilities like internalization
Adobe Analytics a storybook react route
so this is very opinionated set of tools
and with the framework so I will just go
through the the generate the app
structure in detail so this is how our
app structure looks like where we have
the route reducer action saga and test
where we have the components inside the
app and inside the components we have
reducer action saga and test so this is
how typically a app structure looks like
and it's standard across all the
products that we use and developers are
very comfortable with this structure and
they can easily identify what they write
and how they need to document it and
this is the coolest thing that we built
the two generators one is AB generator
and UI generator so app generator is
basically like you just give a command
and it will ask you to - it will
generate in the boilerplate and
developers can straightaway right start
writing the business requirements so
even inside this app
we have the generator for models routes
a lot of things there inside there so
developers are free to use or they can
create the the structure acutely with
this generators with this couple of
commands and the other ECU I generator
so this is based on the this is for the
components so we have defined a
boilerplate for building reusable
components so it's standard across the
the products and it's also defined the
component structures and how you should
document it so I will just go through
the the number third is the UI component
libraries so UI component libraries we
use storybook internally to build the
presentation components where it is
reusable across product projects and
hardened through open collaboration with
the design and the business teams and
it's configurable to suit a range of
intended use cases and the good thing is
it's t-mobile and thanks to storybook
for recognizing us along with other tech
giants and thanks and I would like to
just present like what how does our
component libraries looks like so these
are the couple of the component
libraries that we use in channel II and
we have the libraries for the internet
banking your forms and everything is
documented well so that Bella preserve
this can easily use this modules in
their products and we use the semantic
version to upgrade each libraries but
how we achieve all these things and how
we implemented this in our products so
that's a challenging part but this this
is the the thing that we want to also
highlight and share principles that we
follow so number one is no reinvent so
given that all the production like ready
libraries are built by the community
there is no benefit to build by our own
so in-house library
tend not to cover in a fuse cases and we
find it hard to get up to date so you
introduce only minimal libraries if
required and number two reduce choices
we have too many libraries in the NPM
and developers often confuse to choose
the right libraries and these are all
that all time consuming and not
productive
so using this Falcon framework that we
built the product in term product team
can focus on building things that brings
valid to the business and our three
standard guidelines so we defined
recommended application layout structure
components to bring consistent
development and production environment
to the product teams based on our data
we also defined the browser support
policy for where we want to build our
product to the trajector customers not
just to the something that is not
relevant to a customer and number four
is the flexible so we were we don't want
to limit teams potential instead we want
to encourage team to find a better way
to improve together also also although
this contradict with our opinion two
choices most of the team preferred
decisions made for them so that they can
focus on building products so apart
apart from the benefits so I would like
to share the results what we have
observed or what we have got through
this journey so we and if I'd that there
is a drastic decrease in time to first
meaningful pane for product remake and
the second is we work very closely with
the design design and the business to
build the standardize component and
consistent experience so there's operon
collaboration and first iterations
between the the products and last happy
developers so we value our developers
and developers feel happy and confirm
working with the chord base and they
find it hard easier to add enhancement
to existing products and also easier
sprint planning since react is easily
composable so these are the things that
work for us just to recap so on this
digital product transformation to build
consistent user experience and high
quality products these are the things
that work for us
one is the app structure where it gives
the developers to develop or start
onboarding start onboarding the product
quickly and generators where app
generator and component charities help
us to kickstart development and also
enable us to have faster iteration and
number three is the UI component library
with storybook worked well for us for to
ensure components are seamlessly
integrated with the products also
documented for referencing anytime last
not but least easier unit testing so we
find it found it very easier to do unit
testing with set of libraries that we
choose like relax act or redux saga
etcetera thank you
[Applause]